نعلم جميعًا أن شخصًا واحدًا
يأكله البعوض على قيد الحياة ربما
يكون أنت واحدًا منهم ، لكننا الآن
نتعلم المزيد عن سبب قول دراسة جديدة
أنه يمكن أن يكون لها علاقة بكيفية
شمك لرائحة
توم فورمان من CNN موجود هنا  لشرح ،
أعلم أن هناك الكثير من الناس يتساءلون عن
سبب كونهم مغناطيسًا للبعوض توم
بالطبع هذا بحث يومي مثير
من جامعة روكفلر في
نيويورك حيث يقومون بالكثير من العمل الرائع
على هذا ما وجدوه هو  هذه
الرائحة الجلدية لها جاذبية
واضحة للبعوض لدى بعض الناس كم هي
محددة لدرجة أنه في بعض الحالات
يقولون إن الأشخاص الذين يجتذبون
البعوض أكثر جاذبية 100 مرة
من الأشخاص الآخرين القريبين في هذا
الظرف الآن ما هي
رائحة الجلد التي تجعل  فرق وضعوا
هذه الأكمام أه على الناس ثم
جمعوا رائحة جلدهم ثم
قاموا باختبارها ضد البعوض
ووجدوا أن ما كان عبارة عن نوع من
الأحماض الدهنية الكربوكسيلية الكربوكسيلية ماذا يفعل
الكربوكسيل  تعمل الأحماض الكربوكسيلية
حقًا على سحب البعوض فقط من
إناث البعوض بالطريقة التي
لا يعضها ذكور البعوض وتعطي
رائحة خفيفة هذه الأحماض من الجبن
والأقدام والتي لا تبدو جذابة
لتبدأ بها إذا كان البعوض لا
يزعجك  قد تواجه مشكلة أخرى
ولكن هذا هو الشيء
الذي حاول البعوض آنا قوله ماذا لو تمكنا
بطريقة ما من قطع المستقبلات الموجودة على هذا
البعوض حتى لا يتمكنوا من شم
رائحتها أيضًا ، لا يهم أن
لديهم أنظمة احتياطية لا يزالون يلاحقونها  هؤلاء
الأشخاص أكثر من أي شخص آخر ،
فالسؤال الآن هو هل يمكنك الخروج
بنوع من المستحضر المعطل أو شيء
يمكن أن يضعه الناس على جلدهم من
شأنه أن يقمع هذا ، لذلك على
الأقل هؤلاء الأشخاص ليسوا أكثر
جاذبية للبعوض من أي شخص
آخر  وربما يمكنك الوصول إلى
حيث ليسوا بهذه الجاذبية الكبيرة المهمة
لأنك تذكر البعوض بصرف النظر
عن كونه مصدر إزعاج وغير
مريح 700 مليون
يعاني الأشخاص سنويًا من أمراض ينقلها البعوض
مثل زيكا وحمى الضنك والملاريا ، لذا
فهذه أخبار كبيرة قد تبدو مضحكة بطريقة ما
ولكن من نواحٍ أخرى قد تكون
مهمة حقًا آنا نعم أضحك
لأنني اعترفت في بداية
المقطع  أنني كنت أولئك الأشخاص الذين يتعرضون
للعض طوال الوقت ، ويبدو أنني
أؤجل رائحة الجبن جيدًا ،
أعتقد عندما
تذهب إلى الشاطئ في المرة القادمة سأخبر
زوجي أننا تعلمناك "  إعادة
رائحة حلوة ورائعة نعم نعم
سيكون ذلك جيدًا وسيكون بمثابة
مسرحية جيدة في هذه المرحلة ، لذا على أي حال هناك
أخبار مثيرة ونأمل في الربيع المقبل عندما
نتعامل جميعًا مع هذا ، ربما نكون قد
أحرزنا بعض التقدم في اكتشاف
إذا كان هناك طريقة ما لوقف هذا